-Luke, it is great to see you.
Thank you so much for --
Yeah, okay.
Alright. Yeah.
Ow!
We have a lot in common.
[ Laughter ]
-Do tell.
-Besides looks.
We're identical twins.
[ Laughter ]
I know that you're --
You have an Airstream.
You own an Airstream.
-I do. Yeah.
-Talk to me about this.
-It was sort of one of those
kind of COVID impulse buys.
My wife and I had just moved to
Austin, Texas.
You know, we were going to...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...put down some roots.
-I love Austin.
-COVID hit, and our really cool
loft became like a jail cell.
And we were just
kind of trapped in there
and figured I always wanted
to do it,
always wanted an Airstream,
always wanted to do that
big cross-country trip,
so we finally did it.
-You did it?
-Yeah.
-When I get my Airstream,
I kind of -- I rent it almost.
For like a week.
[ Laughter ]
Or less.
-I think that means
you don't have an Airstream.
-I don't currently have
an Airstream.
[ Laughter ]
But at one point,
I had one for a week.
And I had it.
I set it up on a beach.
-Oh, cool, man.
Aren't they the greatest?
It's not the roomiest thing
in the world.
-I turned into
a different person.
I was like -- I was the dude.
I was the man. I loved it.
I lived in -- My trailer
neighbors were all my buds.
-Yeah, man.
-We had our -- Yeah.
We had our own thing,
our own deal.
We loved it.
We were sharing food.
-Yeah. That trip sort of became
about, for us, like,
finding where we actually wanted
to live.
-Yeah.
-And we went to all
the mountains all through the
west and ended up in Montana,
which is where the Airstream
is now parked at our house
that we built.
-Is that right?
-Yeah, that was sort of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kind of homesteaded up there
a little bit.
-You know what we did?
I had this Airstream.
And then to be really honest,
I do own an Airstream
because when the pandemic
happened, we all shut down,
I mentioned, you know,
before on the show
that I love this Airstream,
and they gave me one to make
into a studio for our show.
-Oh, cool, man.
-To do the show
from my backyard.
-Amazing.
-Yeah. So it was because of
Airstream that we got to
actually do the show
for a couple episodes, so thank
you, Airstream, for doing that.
-Wow.
-It was a wild, bizarre thing.
But I never changed it. I kept
it as a television studio.
-So basically all through COVID,
you and I were in Airstreams.
We are the same person, bro.
[ Laughter ]
-Is there any downside
to traveling just living
on the road on an Airstream?
-The only downside was
that we have a cat.
And it's a Bengal cat, so it's
kind of like a high-tech cat.
It's not like a normal --
-What does a high-tech cat mean?
-It's just got more going on
than a house cat
that sits there
and licks itself or whatever.
It's got a lot of energy.
That was tough. It did not like
the confined space.
-What did you have to do?
-Well, at first, we let it
kind of run around,
and then coyotes
were coming around,
and, you know,
that wasn't very good.
So my wife got a leash
for our cat.
And turns out, it's not
very easy to walk a cat.
-I was going to say,
can you walk a cat?
Is that possible?
-You can.
Just not near trees or anything
that they can climb.
-They climb trees?
-Yeah.
-Well, obviously, cat in
the tree or whatever --
That actually happens?
-Yeah, that old song and dance.
-Yeah, I've seen it in cartoons,
but they really do
climb up trees?
-Oh, yeah. She'd be sitting
there just holding the leash.
-You brought a --
You actually have a picture.
-Yeah, proof.
-Here's your cat. Wow.
[ Laughter ]
That really did happen.
You ended up getting it out of
the tree, I'm assuming.
-Yeah, yeah. We got her back.
We got her back.
-No. You left her there.
-She's still in that tree.
-Not only do you star in the
biggest show on television,
but you have your
first country music
single out right now, buddy.
Look at this.
"No Horse to Ride."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congratulations.
-Thanks, man.
-How did this all come about?
-I've always played music.
Music sort of came first.
Yeah. I grew up in church
and been playing music
since I was probably
10 or 11 years old.
Just something I always
stuck with.
I was always in bands
when I lived in L.A.,
and someone kind of caught wind
that I was writing some stuff,
and one thing led to another.
And I got a record deal,
so here we are.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"No Horse to Ride"
is out right now.
Are you going to do an album?
-Yes.
I start recording February.
Should be about probably
end of March-ish.
-No way!
-Yeah, yeah.
-Go, Luke Grimes.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, congratulations, man.
-Thanks, dude.
-It's all happening.
-Thanks, man.
-Can we talk about
"Yellowstone"?
Because it's the biggest thing
to happen
in television since "Seinfeld."
I don't know what else to say.
It's a giant, giant show
that everyone is watching.
There's a lot of drama going on
right now
between your character's
siblings,
and I don't want to spoil
anything.
But looks like you're not going
to spoil anything either.
-Lips are sealed.
-Yeah, you're really good
at this stuff.
Do you know what's
going to happen?
-No, I don't.
I think some of the cast
know the end.
Some have been told.
Some haven't.
-You don't want to know.
-I don't. I don't.
And I don't think Taylor,
who writes our show,
wants me to know either.
I don't know.
It might affect the way you do
something or play something.
And it's kind of fun to
experience it this way anyway.
It's sort of like life.
-How do you describe
your character?
I've heard descriptions saying
your character is kind of
like Michael Corleone
in "The Godfather."
-Yeah, that's been kind of
a reference throughout,
but we'll have to see.
I think that's what we're all
kind of waiting to see.
Can he kind of step up and man
up and do the things necessary
to help the family
keep the place or not?
I think that's what we're all
kind of watching to find out.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Luke Grimes
in the midseason finale of
"Yellowstone."
Take a look at this.
-Can you come tomorrow
and get the rest on the road?
-Let me just ask my wife.
-Yeah, you do that, son.
Whatever she says, stick to it.
-Yeah, tends to be
the safest move.
-You're stronger than I was.
Guess that's how it's supposed
to be.
I love you, son.
-Come on, now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who's cooler than this guy?
Luke, before you go, now you're
a country music star.
You're a star of "Yellowstone"
now.
I thought we'd put you to a test
in a new game called
"Line or Lyric:
Yellowstone Edition."
Okay? Here's how this works.
I'm going to read a line off
this card.
You have to tell me if it's
dialogue from "Yellowstone"
or if it's
a country music lyric.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
-Then we'll show you video of
the correct answer.
You ready for this?
-Yeah. Yeah, let's do it.
-Alright. Here's the first one.
"You are the trailer park,
I am the tornado."
-That is Beth Dutton for sure.
100%.
-You think Beth Dutton 100%?
-100%.
-It is not
a country music lyric?
-That is my final answer.
-"You are the trailer park."
♪ I am the torn-- ♪
Alright, well, let's see
if he's right.
-You are the trailer park.
I am the tornado.
[ Ding! ]
-Beth Dutton!
How awesome is Beth Dutton?
Alright, here we go.
How about this one?
"I should've been a cowboy.
I should've learned
to rope and ride."
[ Laughter ]
-That's a country song.
-Let me see.
-♪ I should've been a cowboy ♪
♪ Should've learned
to rope and ride ♪
-Back in the mullet days.
-Mullet days.
Yeah, Toby Keith right there.
Alright.
How about this one?
"We got so much to talk about.
Why aren't we talkin'?"
-"Yellowstone"?
-Is it "Yellowstone" or is it
country music lyric?
-Can I ask the audience?
-We got a lot to talk about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We got so much to talk about,
why aren't we talkin'?
[ Ding! ]
-That's exactly right!
"Why aren't we talkin'?"
That's you.
Casey Dutton, Luke Grimes,
everybody.
"Yellowstone" returns this
summer on Paramount Network.
We'll be right back with
a performance from Protoje.
Stick around, everybody!